los cuales son los principales
cuestionamientos que hacen al gobierno
de guillermo lasso
saludos cordiales
latinoamérica y el mundo y gracias por
la invitación estimado andrés
efectivamente los puntos referenciales
que presenta el presidente guillermo
largo no corresponden a la realidad
sobre todo de los sectores populares
aquí el movimiento indígena los sectores
populares llevamos a dos mesas de
diálogo los puntos centrales primero la
situación de los combustibles el
problema agrario que tiene relación
directa con la canasta básica de los
ecuatorianos el problema de la
inseguridad el problema de la situación
financiera de nuestras economías hay más
de 4 millones de créditos que dependemos
las economías y que en este momento no
han sido atendidas hay un proceso
abusivo del sistema financiero en
recaudar perdón estos temas el tema
minero que están ingresando a nuestro
territorio sin consulta previa libre e
informada garantiza la constitución el
tema de los veintiún derechos colectivos
que no han sido asumidos por el gobierno
nacional ni siquiera en las condiciones
de educación intercultural bilingüe hay
un proceso de privatización de los
sectores de estratégica
las cuales dentro de una valoración
general que hemos hecho los diferentes
sectores sociales hemos visto que el
presidente de la república no ha
cumplido con las demandas centrales que
demandamos los sectores populares de la
uat ahora ustedes reclaman que estos
problemas no sólo vienen del gobierno a
lazo sino que de décadas atrás y también
se extienden a otras comunidades no es
así
efectivamente nosotros hemos de lo que
corresponde a la etapa en este caso
desde el 24 de mayo del 2021 lo que
debería haber resuelto el presidente de
la república no podemos trasladar la
responsabilidad de los anteriores
gobiernos pero creemos importante los
temas sustanciales por ejemplo como el
presidente de la república al
incrementar al incrementar el precio de
los combustibles dijo que no iba a
afectar en este caso a la canasta básica
pero sin embargo no ha tenido una
política de control de precios a tal
punto que se recauda por constante
inversión pero a la vez también te deja
al mercado libre que recuperan a partir
de la especulación este es un tema que
en este caso las condiciones mínimas de
la gente ya no es posible es obtenerla
otro tema en el tema educativo el
presidente de la república se
comprometió en este caso garantizar el
ingreso a las universidades pero no es
simplemente eliminando en la prueba para
el ingreso sino garantizando un
presupuesto desde el estado para que se
pueda en este caso garantizar el 10 por
ciento en todas las universidades más
bien lo que ha hecho el presidente de la
república es red y el presupuesto en el
área de la salud en el área de la
agricultura la ganadería en el área de
la seguridad en el área de la ahora hoy
se convocó a una movilización nacional a
partir del 13 de junio y usted reconoció
que esto podría ser perjudicial para los
grupos sociales porque a seguir adelante
entonces
nosotros no hemos dicho que estaría una
psp algo que vaya en contra de los
grupos sociales lo que sí estamos
diciendo es una vez agotado los
procedimientos han llegado las
propuestas en frentes tiempo dos mesas
de diálogo y que el gobierno nacional en
lugar de resolver los problemas más bien
ha estigmatizado y criminalizado y ha
perseguido a los dirigentes en ese
sentido nosotros no tenemos otras
opciones llegarán y estar lo que dice el
artículo 98 de la constitución el
derecho a la resistencia en este caso
cuando un derecho está siendo vulnerado
en el ecuador